hey guys it's vadim with max tech and
welcome to our new macbook pro buyer's
guide
[Music]
so as you guys probably know apple made
their new 14 and 16 inch macbook pro
configurators extremely complicated with
various chip options with different core
counts and features as well as more
options for ram so it's no wonder why
many of you guys are commenting non-stop
about which model to purchase so this
video is our official buyer's guide for
the new m1 pro and m1 max macbook pros
where i'm going to take you through the
mistakes you need to avoid when buying
one of these new macs and i'm also going
to recommend different models for each
use case and i'm going to reveal the
model that i bought for myself so let's
get right into it first up i know a lot
of you guys are gonna be tempted into
making the mistake of going all out on
the chip configuration that you buy when
you really don't need to
so let me give you guys some perspective
so you can make a rational decision if
you really think about it the current m1
chip is already more than fast enough
for most people even those who actually
do productivity work like photo editing
video editing music production
programming etc for example the m1
macbook pro literally outperformed our
15 000 mac pro in terms of xcode
programming performance and in lightroom
classic it wasn't as good but it
outperformed the 2400 16 inch intel
macbook pro and it was keeping up with
the crazy 27 inch desktop imac and for
the most common 4k h.264 video editing
work the m1 ship closed the gap even
further so because of that we actually
replaced our main editing 27-inch imac
that angelica used every day with a
24-inch m1 imac that edits video even
faster and more reliably than my five
thousand dollar imac pro which is mind
blowing so the point that i'm trying to
make is that the m1 is already more than
powerful enough for most people so if
you think you need to go and fully spec
out the new 14 inch macbook pro with 32
gpu cores and 64 gigs of ram for 3 700
you're probably wrong that machine is
gonna be overkill for 99
of the people out there and chances are
the base model 14 inch macbook pro with
both a binned cpu and a gpu is going to
be more than fast enough for a lot of
people out there now if you have no idea
what the term bind means i'm gonna
explain that really quick because it's
extremely important for this video as
you can see right here i have a graphic
of apple's new m1 pro chip labeled by
anantek and you can see the cluster of
cpu performance cores right here and the
cluster of gpu cores right here now
since nothing is perfect in life
sometimes there are imperfections in
these chips like for example a couple of
the gpu cores have some flaws that
impact performance so instead of tossing
this chip in the trash can and losing
all of that investment apple simply
disables those two flawed cores turning
the 10 core chip into an eight core and
then they sell it at a discount to make
it cheaper for consumers now the same
thing can be applied to the gpu cores
with apple disabling two of them instead
of tossing out the chip entirely
creating a 14 core gpu and that's how we
ended up with the double bend base model
14 inch macbook pro for two thousand
dollars with you having to pay an extra
three hundred dollars just to get a
perfect unbind chip and this also
applies to that 24 core gpu upgrade for
500. it's really just a 32 core m1 max
chip with eight of the cores disabled so
apple can offer you a cheaper upgrade
option now with all that said and
explained i want to mention to you guys
that we bought eight different m1 pro
and m1 max configurations so we can
deliver the best comparison videos out
there so if you appreciate our efforts
subscribe right now and definitely check
out our merch like this sharpie edition
t-shirt down in the merch shelf below
and be sure to use the m1 pro promo code
to save 20
on all of our merch with that said let's
move on to the next mistake which is
actually thinking that these macbook
pros are overpriced compared to buying
an m1 macbook pro which is completely
wrong the m1 macbook pro starts at 1300
and comes with only 256 gigs of ssd and
8 gigs of ram now if you want to match
the same 512 gig ssd and 16 gigs of ram
as the new 14 inch base model has the
price of the m1 goes up to 1700
only 300 shy of the 14 inch so let me
quickly fly through all of the
advantages you get for that extra 300
bucks of course you get the new design
language with the flat top and bottom
you get much more ports including an
extra thunderbolt 4 port an sd card slot
an hdmi port and of course max safe
charging the 512 gigabyte ssd is
actually much faster on the 14 inch
since it uses newer technology the 16
gigabytes of ram is also much faster
using lp ddr5
megahertz ram instead of the older and
slower lp ddr4x
4266 megahertz ram then on top of that
add in the larger 14.2 inch display with
a 3k resolution instead of 2.5 k as well
as the new mini led display technology
that can go up to 600 nits of brightness
compared to just 500 and then add in the
pro motion 120 hertz display refresh
rate tech making it basically the best
display in any laptop ever then of
course you've got the much better 1080p
webcam that takes in two times more
light for a cleaner image then add in
much better quality speakers and other
details like a new 3.5 millimeter
headphone jack that supports higher
impedance which kind of sounds like it
has a built-in deck then you add in the
new keyboard with a full set of function
keys that replaces the touch bar as well
as the new cooling system that moves 50
percent more air and the upgraded
external display support as well and of
course don't forget the much faster m1
pro chip even the one with the bend
8-core cpu and 14 core gpu so in reality
that extra 300 for the base 14-inch is
an absolute no-brainer if you're already
buying a similarly spec'd m1 macbook pro
and i'd even go as far as to say that
everyone should be avoiding the m1
macbook pro at all costs if at all
possible so either buy the m1 macbook
air on sale on amazon for
929 dollars right now or go straight to
the 14 inch macbook pro for 2 000
i'm not even kidding it's worth it now
with all of that said if you're already
dead set on buying one of these new
macbook pros let's jump right into the
configurator starting with the base
14-inch model this model is meant for
almost everybody who does even a decent
amount of hobby productivity work since
it's gonna fly through many of those
common tasks however the first thing i
would do is go down to the power adapter
options and pay the extra 20 bucks for
the 96 watt power adapter because it
gives you the 50 fast charging in 30
minutes feature and as far as the ram i
honestly think that for most people 16
gigs of unified memory is going to be
perfectly fine because first of all it's
much faster this year and we've already
proven that apple's unified memory in
the m1 max is incredibly efficient at
handling massive workloads compared to
16 gigs of traditional ram in a windows
laptop as you can see in this chart on
top of that the ssds in these macbook
pros are much faster which will also
greatly improve the performance of ssd
caching which acts as makeshift memory
if you ever do run a bit low on ram so i
would recommend 16 gigs for most people
unless you want to buy it for the very
long term and you really like the extra
piece of mind of having 32 gigs now on
top of that both the 14 and 16 inch
models come with 512 gigs of ssd and i
would honestly recommend everyone to
spend the extra 200
for the one terabyte ssd option because
it's just such a good bang for the buck
but i definitely recommend holding off
on buying the crazy ssd options like the
8 terabyte ssd because it's insanely
expensive and most people just won't be
able to fill it up instead you could
literally buy a 4 terabyte external
thunderbolt 3 ssd for only 700 on amazon
right now if you want to store files for
the long term so i'm going to leave a
link down in the description if you're
interested but with that said let's
pivot over to the chip options just in
case you're willing to venture away from
the base model and pay for some chip
upgrades which i would definitely
recommend if you're actually using your
mac professionally for a business or to
make money first of all if you pay the
extra 300 to get the unbend m1 pro chip
with the 10 core cpu and the 16 core gpu
you need to realize that you are now
only 200 away from the base 2500
starting price of the 16 inch macbook
pro which is a much better buy because
you're getting a larger display with
higher resolution quite a bit better
battery life a much more powerful 140
watt power adapter and a larger and more
useful trackpad which i think together
make it a no-brainer for 200 more so
because of that i think anyone willing
to spend 300 on that chip upgrade on the
14-inch should just jump straight to the
inch macbook pro unless you really want
the smaller 14 inch size for portability
and if that's the case for you here are
the chip upgrades that i would recommend
for the 14 inch first of all if you're
someone who mainly relies on cpu
performance for things like programming
music production or photo editing then
i'd say the 200 upgrade to get a 10 core
cpu is definitely worth it because the
crazy m1 max chip won't really do that
much for you since you don't need the
extra graphics power instead upgrading
to 32 gigabytes of ram is a smart choice
for all of those professional tasks
because they can use a lot of memory
especially high-end photo editing but as
far as upgrading to 64 gigs of ram i
don't think it's worth it for 99 of the
people out there because you're forced
to first upgrade to the 24 core m1 max
ship before spending another 400 to
upgrade to 64 gigs of ram bringing the
price up to 3 300 for a 14 inch so only
go with 64 gigs if you absolutely know
you need it like if you're gonna be
running vms or doing the craziest
graphics rendering out there and that
finally brings us to the graphic side of
the equation with the m1 max chip and
who should actually be buying it but
before i get into that i want to put
something into perspective the base 2500
16 inch macbook pro model is so powerful
that it actually outperforms the very
best 3 500 i9 intel 16 inch macbook pro
in terms of cpu performance
and it outperforms the insanely
expensive 800
radeon pro 5600m upgrade so comparing
the new 16 inch to the previous one
you're getting more performance in every
aspect alongside a bunch of extra
features like the display and 10 extra
hours of battery life for literally a
thousand dollars less than before with
that base 2500 model so keep that in
mind now moving on to very high end
graphics related use cases if you're
dead set on buying 32 gigs of ram either
for the 14 or 16 inch model you should
absolutely hands down spend 200
on the 24 core m1 max chip upgrade
you're first of all going to get 50
higher graphics performance instantly
for just 200 more but on top of that
you're getting better external display
support you're getting a larger cooling
system to cover the larger chip and
you're literally getting double the
video encode engines and double the
prores encode and decode engines now
that last part is absolutely huge for
video editors because most video exports
are actually limited by those encoders
as you can see in this chart where the
much more expensive max with much faster
graphics barely improved export times
and even the m1 chip was limited by the
encoders so there's a pretty good chance
that the much faster 16 core gpu in the
m1 pro isn't gonna export videos that
much faster than the regular m1 chip but
since the m1 max chip features double
the encode engines it's likely going to
export videos at least twice as fast as
the m1 pro chip and that goes for prores
work as well so if you're editing and
exporting many videos per week or you
want those other advantages just pay the
extra 200 for the 24 core m1 max chat
and now let's finish off with who should
be buying the insane 32 core gpu well if
you're a gamer and you want the fastest
possible gaming performance buy the 32
core for sure and you'll likely be just
fine with the standard 32 gigs of ram
now if you're doing very high end
graphics related work like 3d rendering
or editing raw video which is extremely
gpu intensive then you should also be
buying the 32 core gpu and in those
cases 64 gigabytes of ram might actually
make sense if you know you can use it
but like i mentioned earlier in this
video if you're not going to be making
money or doing professional work with
one of these macbook pros then you'll
likely be just fine with even the base
14-inch macbook pro for two thousand
dollars so hopefully this video helped
you make a decision and if it did go
ahead and use the links down below for
the best deals on those macbook pros and
ssd accessories and be sure to click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one definitely check
out our merch with the m1 pro promo code
check out one of those two videos right
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video what
is this that do you think
nope
video recording